ja ich habe angst
der teleport sich einfach zu mir
hallo ich meine lieben frauen und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft hero und zwar wollte ich
heute mal eine folge macht und wo ich
einfach mal durch die wälder reise ganz
ganz weit weg und ich werde es bei magic
mirror machen wo ich den ich auf meine
stadt fokussiere als auf statt blau dass
der daran mich immerhin teleportiert und
dann werde ich einfach mal richtig weit
reisen mit jockey und versuchen
irgendwie an ganz viele sachen ran zu
kommen damit ich mir dementsprechend
irgendwann dann ging's machen kann und
werde ich werde jetzt erstmal magic
mirror machen und ich habe irgendwie
angst dass diese blöden peters aus
shopping die zu mir kommen
magic mirror ränder perlender perlen ich
wirklich nur eine augen
die angst der stadt pink zu mir kommt
und dass sie mich dann boxen ende augen
empfehlen
ich bin echt angst kann ich die sache
nicht irgendwie einen geilen rucksack
erst mal packen packt erstmal dass er
rein was irgendwie hab ich irgendwie
einer vermittler sein könnte so ändert
tatsächlich will sogar mehr als ein
machen gold 1 was soll ich bin meinen
rucksack drin gewesen
nein
77 und diamanten
da kann ich mir da noch ein machen so
ich habe daher noch gold blöcke da
stimmt com ist jetzt egal ich mache
jetzt erstmal in seinem magic mirror so
damit wenn ich weg bin dass ich dann
immer wieder mich hierhin teleportieren
kann weil der funktioniert nämlich
moment jetzt ist ja so der muss nämlich
grau sein also über dem himmel ja genau
darf nicht sein und zwar kann ich mich
so zurück teleportieren in die stadt
macht das jetzt einfach mal wird dann
definitiv nichts mehr gebaut hier wird
definitiv nichts mehr drüber gebaut
hatte sich jetzt verdienst diese kann
ich dir nicht
ich möchte ihn hier traf aktivieren habe
ich in rafz aktiviert also ich glaub ich
hab den da dort drauf aktiviert aber ich
muss den einem backpack mit rum
befördern das hat man mir nämlich auch
beschrieben die punkt.de sitzen backpack
gesichts felsen
ach schön hier wohl bisschen was gebaut
so der ist jetzt da und dann nehme ich
denn jetzt da raus
diese funktioniert das nicht oder
mussten die unter der erde machen muss
den unter der erde einsetzen
was ist wenn ich jetzt hier bin und in
einsätzen möchte er hier geht es nicht
oder muss ich die ganze zeit irgendwo
sein was ist denn jetzt da hinten so
magic mirror lärm mit luca im moment
hier geht's auch nicht leisten dass man
für mich einfach zu blöd gerade
hier geht's wieder jetzt komme ich hier
raus die wände ich den denn an
hallo herr wie wendig den denn an wie
mache ich denn dann dass der hier
irgendwie dann wieder so weiß bescheid
mach ich hier so und was passiert jetzt
bin ich ja wieder aus dem haus draußen
ja und wie aktiviere ich den erstmal
muss ich die ganze zeit bei den displays
bringen muss die ganze zeit in backpack
drin haben vielleicht kann ich auch mal
einfach habe ich nicht hier noch
irgendwo beck payback payback
so soll ich dir drin checke ich mir den
daraus als 50 mal muss sich verzaubern
oder bin ich einfach nur kaffee
verzaubern kann ich in ordentlich hier
darüber bin dann ist er sodann kann ich
mich aus dem haus irgendwie raus zu
deportieren aber so richtig auf eine
stadt anwenden kann ich dir nicht ich
kann den zwei umbenennen auf jetzt
irgendwie statt blau statt blau weiß ich
dir jetzt auch statt blau anwender weiß
ich nicht ja gut soll und setzt auch
erstmalig egal sein
schreibt mir einfach mal wie ich den
verwendet das ist jetzt schon ein
bisschen kaka irgendwie wohl irgendwas
abgerissen
das speziell auf die wirklich etwas
rostock ii ach der ist ja bei mir im
haus oder helfer warum ist extrem hoch
ist
der soll darum darf bleiben soll ist
eine folge werden wo ich mir einfach nur
so ach du bist ja wieder halb tot
wo ich einfach nur unterwegs bin und
verglich sie kahl essenzen zu bekommen
aber nein ich sterbe wieder fast ich
brauche sei damit jetzt hier nicht als
normales gefühl
ok am markt so und jetzt suchen wir
einfach fck lizenzen und wir gehen
ziemlich ich nehme mir zwei folgen so
auf indem einfach ist karl sachen suchen
und was nämlich auch noch sagen wollte
ich hab wollen wir eine folge
aufgenommen fletcher wiederum geschmack
ich bin jetzt umgestiegen auf die
historie
die qualität müsse die gleiche sein auch
mal der stifter mal hätte ich mal gesagt
mitgenommen
hier waren wir eigentlich schon richtig
oft ich hätte mal einfach mal die
koordinaten in chats schreiben sollen
antwortete mich mal geantwortet
behinderte [ __ ] stadt pinggau
koordinaten krieg gehen hoffe ich dass
ich dennoch wagen
wie stellt man gleich einfach widerlich
und schoki hier kommen wie kommentiert
ich brauche einfach mal ein goldenes als
ich nehme bei bombay auf dann gibt er
mir dann soll sondern dass auf jeden
fall schon viel viel schilliger
mitfliegen und davon so vor allem wälder
mit diesem dinge lange entfernungen über
land sind der mega zierlich aber wälder
war es echt scheiße platz so jetzt mal
ausschau halten sind hier irgendwo hexie
tatsachen
ich weiß nicht wie viel ich brauche ich
glaube ich brauche locker 10 12 ich
glaube sogar 14 hinten war ich ja
überall stehen sind dabei führen die
cavs schon der vorstadt nur cap meinte
dass er halt wirklich selten nach mexiko
lizenzen ausschau gehalten hat ich kann
auch mal zwischendurch ja eigentlich
kann ich aber eben noch im jura top
player api saalbau hört dass bei einer
ernst den hätte ich eigentlich auch noch
mal reparieren können glöden annehmen
kann zauberstäbe ja nicht reparieren
egal was wollt ihr alle von wave
klatsche doch an ein bisschen lachen
der dessen angst jetzt okay das war
vielleicht ein bisschen eng so ich
fresse mal ein paar potatoes alter das
vielleicht ein bisschen mich verzaubert
also ich hab doch eigentlich stärker und
so was alles aber wieso haben die mich
dann so leicht geklatscht so schnell
das verstehe ich nicht wieso ich denn so
schnell geklatscht das ist echt
verwunderlich aber wahrscheinlich
welchem eine rüstung einfach nahezu kein
bisschen verzaubert hat ich habe ja fast
nichts drauf hätte ihm tief rüstung und
kenneth i fristen ist jetzt auch nicht
so viel besser aber auf jeden fall
besser wenn man dass man so auf die ja
auch das ist auch an der elektriker
sense auf jeden fall besser was so
schnelligkeit angeht und nicht am
wettrennen rehbaum welchen jetzt von
allen gewusst ich muss mich auch mal
richtig heftig an pfeilen bedienen bei
kev weil der liga bogen jetzt eine
heftige waffen und jetzt auch noch an
breaking his scheiße drauf was willst du
denn jetzt tut pizza.de vergifte die
vergiftet ich muss nur meine hand
nämlich nicht mehr vergiftet dank
übrigens ein ganzen tipps die mir da mal
gesendet werden und schreib mir diesmal
wieder alle in die kommentare wie ich
den links verwenden den magic mirror und
was auch sehr wichtig ist schreibt mir
mal für die nächste folge jetzt schon
team in die kommentare weil die nächste
folge sondern auch wieder seine folge
werden wo ich dann so ein bisschen nach
sachen hier suchen was hab ich jetzt
endlich zwei elektriker senses von
vodafone von oben denkst du denkst du
kriegst mich hier
barth aus dem flugplatz digger kurz wenn
deine sachen so jetzt ab rheine die
festung endlich will ich gehe immer in
der hoffnung darein dass da ich habe ja
nicht mal fackeln fackeln ich bin
vorbereitet wieder ein stück scheiße
ja okay ich werde mich besser
vorbereiten okay okay ist wahrscheinlich
die nächsten raus ihr seid auch geil so
habe ich es gern so habe ich es gerne
hauptsach richtig viel mehr machen wir
dieser folge jetzt nicht sondern eine
hexe kahl so folgern wir das jetzt
einfach eine folgenlose so richtig die
ganzen leute immer passion damit wir die
mal zeigen wer ist der wahre hier zu
hause
wie man wird das dann auch mal somit
statt rot ablaufen und statt geld die
werden dann einfach auch so vermittelt
daher keine andere auf jeden fall aber
wir brauchen einfach einfach wirklich
fackeln ich fresse erstmal kurz fritz
nicht dass sie da wo ich reingehe das
natürlich nicht so gut dass ich etwa die
kartoffeln die braten elendig sda zu
minecraft erfahrung also schreibt mir
ganz ganz viele themen kommentare spam
durch so viele wollt schreibt mir
richtig viele themen damit wenn ich dann
nächstes mal dann richtig los hier
das dann richtig viel hat worüber ich
reden kann halter sind wir doch mal viel
zu viele da ziehe ich mich doch lieber
hier hin und ist jetzt nach dem dorf
ach der dahinten blockt oder wie der
blog ehrlich krasser typ alter trotzdem
gleich tot
holt gleich auch jetzt gibt mir noch ob
man nur hier kommt nicht immer mehr ich
möchte euch eure ganzen verdammten
lizenzen hier mal ein paar electric darf
er natürlich schon beherrschen 33 habe
ich schon und ich bin auch schon bei
level 30 also in diesem komischen
türchen hier kann man richtig geile
sachen und sich raus haha wie viele
dörfer
pfeil habe ich elf ist nur noch elf eine
beste ich heiße man hat von dem habe ich
echt ein bisschen respekt der john
walker berserker sondern eine heftige
sache dem alle sogar krasse sachen ihrem
start bei denen läuft schon ein bisschen
länger hier sind so viele nackte angst
krankhafter die mit einer posse das
immer angst habe ich stell mich als
minister gesagt dann immer ja ich habe
angst
ein bisschen zurück aber trotzdem stelle
ich mich an den kann habe ich nicht
eigentlich auch infiniti hier drauf ich
hab nur noch zwei pfeile das ist gut
aber man kann so geil ep farben gehen
hier die ganzen doch doch schaffe ich
noch war übrigens in der folge wo mein
schreibstil abgekratzt habe ich sachen
gemacht wie never ein bisschen ich hab
eine gas trainer gesammelt
ich dachte dass trainer was man einfach
nur tanzen
hast du die unterhalten sich jetzt
schießt ihr motto mein electric darf es
auch gleich kaputt
ich will mir den jetzt noch einmal
fliegt da oben aufs dach obwohl kann ich
da ganz oben überhaupt rein oder ist da
gar nichts besonderes mehr ist immer
noch ganz oben
doch hier ist noch was das ist der liga
ist stärker direkt neben mir dieser
brauch ich habe angst
er telefoniert sich einfach zu mir alter
der telefoniert sich einfach zu mir
dieser scheiß king alte hätte ich nicht
angegriffen sagt man fragt man fragt man
nach scheiße muss man schoko junge liga
nicht dass jetzt noch hinter mir ist oma
opa wird er stark hat sich krank zu
meinen leben im alter ich bin seit 30
folgen nicht mehr gestorben oder so oha
doch jetzt wo ich hab gerade echt zum
ersten mal richtig vielen folgen so
richtig angst in meinem leben
wenn jetzt noch mal komplett an mich
aber echtes todes letzte umbau hat
keiner
aber da war das auch schon blutet glaube
ich ein schoko müsste er endlich da
unten sein ich muss jetzt auch wieder
nach hause
ja da unten ist das boa wie stark der
auch war du da muss ich mir auf jeden
fall meine meinem eine rüstung
verzaubern wenn ich die nummer klatschen
will weil er kriegt man ja dieses walker
spot an womit man sich dann so platt
teleportieren kann reicht das soll
eigentlich ganz geil sein sonst
ich kenne hier noch mal so ein bisschen
lang laufen vielleicht auch da ist jeder
dieser tolle tempel hier vielleicht kann
ich da noch ein bisschen was rausholen
hier waren der schau mal ändern so dass
mal ganz kurz die aber ich glaube hier
waren auch schon welche drin oder und
ich glaube der boss wird in diesem tempo
nochmal heftiger sein als in dem anderen
hier war auch glaube ich schon jemand ja
sonst wäre das nicht zu verlassen
ja okay dann stecken wir jetzt ab loki
sowohl an wo geht's denn überhaupt die
nach hause ich habe jetzt auch gar keine
existenz gefunden auf dieser blöden
reise hier
wir sind auch gar nicht gereist
eigentlich habe das eigentlich
vorgestellt wie reisebericht 20 minuten
durchgängig jetzt so richtig lange mir
was ist wir treffen einfach blöde tempel
würde burgen aber hey wir haben
elektriker setzen weil die reichen
locker wieder für drei stäbe ja 33
das einleiten doch drei electric
essenzen für drei flugzeuge stäbe dem
bund ab und schneller fliegen
richtig gehört und dann ich habe
übrigens auch schon gedacht dass ich
einfach in diesem wald hier mal ziel und
mein eigenes ding machen weil ich will
keinen krieg mit irgendwem ich bin ein
friedlicher mensch vanjoki hat nur noch
13 leben
ich bin friedlicher mensch ich möchte
mich irgendwie krieg oder büchern und
ich werde ihr niedergemetzelt
aus gründen die ich mir nicht erklären
kann wo bin ich und ja ich suche
eigentlich gar kein spiel deswegen
dachte ich jetzt so ein außenseiter
dahinter stand jetzt ein außenseiter
weil ich halt nicht so wie ich bock
drauf habe
auf stress mit anderen leute deswegen
ist selbst auch brocken kam es mit
deinem oder hier verbindet statt rot und
nein also ich werde mich auch kein ist
mit stadt roth verbinden das werde ich
glaube ich nicht machen ich geh jetzt
mal hier rüber
suzuki du wirst jetzt noch ein bisschen
mühsam auch einfach jetzt mal ich kenne
auch mal einfach jetzt den jockey damit
jetzt mal immer hier sein wissen was da
kein platz mehr
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen bizarr im
bett da kommt auch immer noch ein
bisschen klar füße kam da gerade raus
oder dc scaroni aufnehmen oliver reck
die politik brauche ich doch nicht so
setzt sich wieder hin
hell kongress wieder kaputt gemacht was
noch gar nicht fertig waren
man kriegt trotzdem zieht rosenkranz
wieder anpflanzen
die restlichen kaffee braucht man so
wenn es erstmal 31 für dich ein kleines
städtchen egal jetzt hier was soll das
wasser dass diese funktion ist mit
diesem blöden büro nicht was habe ich da
falsch gemacht
dies funktioniert auch alles hier
eigentlich nein und wenn ich dann
irgendwo im haus bin dann geht wieder
nicht ich glaube ich stelle jetzt echt
mal
wisst ihr was jetzt noch eben machen
können er kommt jetzt noch eben ständig
mal eben schnell denn in den zaun hier
hab ich irgendwo da habe ich zolle ich
noch nirgendwo
da habe ich nicht okay gut da mache ich
jetzt noch mal ganz kurz eben einen
soundcheck ihm so viel kann ein mensch
gott kommt darüber darunter genau jetzt
könnt ihr einfach ganz kurz doch man
gehen ich hab ich mal so ganz kurz ein
kleiner zaun hin öffnet sich ja jockey
dann dein haus wird noch mal irgendwann
fertig sollten uns ein bisschen hier so
sein dass patienten kleiner stall ihn
kommt ich möchte jetzt auch nicht
überziehen meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat ein bisschen verfolgen
dann wieder irgendwie gepanscht und dann
lassen einfach eine bewertung dar und
spam die kommentare vol
was ich in der morgigen folge über was
der quatschen soll wenn ich dann
unterwegs bin wo ist eigentlich der
achter schuldet mir kev noch um eines
kellers auch wieder richtig im eimer
nach diesen kämpft kämpfen jetzt hier
blöder kann man egal